Oh, wait. We're waiting for the
recording. There we go. What's up? I'm
Dex. Uh, this is the AI that works show
where we teach you real hands-on
advanced AI coding, AI implementation,
AI pipeline, AI engineering, context
engineering, um, real world solutions to
building uh, really good AI apps. Hi,
Bob. What do I have to add there?
>> I think that's it. I think today is
going to be
one an episode that will be I think
hopefully educational to a lot of people
which is more about streaming and how
streaming can make your app a lot more
feel almost like a whole different
application uh with and without it and I
think it's one second I'm gonna get this
I'm gonna open the end um okay there we
go
>> yeah this is a really cool topic that
I'm really excited about um I think it
goes really under the hood of some of
the like weird hard annoying problems
with using LMS and especially like
creating really good UX's when LMS are
streaming like partial JSON objects and
how you can show incremental progress
updates in your UI and in your app or on
your CLI well without having to wait for
the entire JSON object to be streamed
out.
>> Exactly. But before when we go into
this, typically you start with
whiteboards, but today I want to do
something different. And I want to start
with examples. I want to go straight to
our example and just show a couple
examples along the way. And before we do
any of this stuff, let's just go look at
chatbt.
When any of us ever use chatbt and I ask
it to go do something, and I'm using the
thinking model right now. It's like
explain why traits are not good for LLMs
for LM generated
generated code and I'll add the more
and I go do this. This whole experience
that's designed by chatbt is actually
goes through and tells you oh you're
thinking you can look at the thinking
code. You can see what it's going to be
thinking along the way. If you want, you
can opt in and skip thinking and go
straight to content generation.
This is all content that actually and
right over here made a section for what
it is. It's actually I can click on and
see exactly what it's thinking for
different steps of the way. Why it does
this is because the generation of code
is all based on the same thing that we
have when we first build websites, which
is response time. anytime I I've never
met someone I've never met a single
major website provider that says, "Hey,
Google loaded fast enough. If you go to
google.com and you search something and
you say like, uh, dogs,
they talk about their search time." I
guess not anymore, but like there's
never been a single time where they've
stopped optimizing load times on Google.
There's never been a single website that
does that. Similarly for your LM
generation code, there's no point at
which no matter how fast the models are
that it will be fast enough because the
fastest thing you could have done is as
soon as the you before the user even
typed out the question, know what
question they were going to ask, have
the answer already ready and load it up
into their machine. The next best thing
you can do is take their answer and take
the question that as soon as they type
it, have the answer already ready on
their exact machine in the exact app in
memory, load it up and answer it back.
At some point, you're going to go down
and make a network call and that will
always be slow even if the LMS are
instantaneous. And the thing is that
today's models are all based on token
generation models. So the mechanisms
that you use to go and display these
responses makes a huge difference. If I
couldn't see what these thought
processes were along the way, it makes
it
>> you just get pissed off and you drop.
You'd be like, I don't have time for
this. I just see a spinner, right? And
so, okay, so you're talking about like
basically this the more you can show
something happen, the earlier you can
show something happening, even if it
isn't the final answer, the more likely
people will actually sit there and wait
for it to finish. And going back to the
theme of our previous last uh last
conversation and the conversation before
that, this UX is important for
steerability. You're not only helping
the person be entertained along the way,
you're helping them have confidence that
this thing that is going to take a
couple seconds to run. It's actually
going to give them something that's
worthwhile and worth sticking around
for. It's like the little doping giving.
>> So if I see the thoughts are wrong, I
might just like exit. I mean, I do this
with cloud code all the time. you exit
out and you'd be like, "Nope, nope,
that's wrong." Like, "Let me go and
start over." without having to wait for
it to do the whole thing.
>> Exactly. That's one of the things I find
very frustrating about sometimes using
cursor, for example, because it doesn't
give me a good incremental UX. So then
I'm kind of stuck trying to digest all
the information and resteer it
correctly. But one of the cool things
cursor has done is they let you go back
and click on a point and checkpoint your
code and go back to that point in the
codebase. It's very, very similar for
anything else. So let's take something
really really simple like ré parsing for
example.
If I were to do any sort of ré parsing
and typically you ask an LM to extract
information. We all know that an LM can
information markdown and we can render
the markdown in a useful way
that is totally valid. But this markdown
uh even if I go render in a really
pretty markdown format and I syntax and
like bolded etc is just going to be a
lot less attractive than something
that's actually like for example these
are real hyperlinks I can click on this
hyperlink is broken. I can even give you
a little notification that's an invalid
URL. The skills can be listed as tags
experiences can be listed in more drop-
down form in a more visually appealing
format. There's a reason most websites
aren't plain text or plain HTML. They
have like CSS on it because style does
matter. But if I were to go and stream
this, I have a couple options. This is
easy to stream. I just render it as it
comes out and the markdown naturally
streams token-wise. This gets a lot more
complicated. So, we're going to talk
about how it actually looks to go and
build more stable streaming systems
along the way over here. And there's a
very
>> Okay, so you're you're converting to
some sort of structured output under the
hood and then you have a renderer like
React components or something that take
that like JSON object and turn it into
this like beautiful view.
>> Exactly. And if we go take something a
little bit more complicated like a
recipe generator, when you go do
something like this, chat GBT is
definitely just rendering tokens, but
what this allows me to build is very
interactive components where even while
it's streaming, I can actually interact
with it. Okay. So, pause this. So,
you're you're running the slider is
basically how many servings do I want?
And you're basically at any given point,
you're able to combine logic that's
interactive in the UI with whatever
incremental output has to date been
streamed by the LLM
>> and it updates in real time. Okay.
>> Exactly. So, if I if I and this is the
beauty of doing things like this is the
code is actually not complex. So,
everyone I think should be able to build
applications like this along the way,
but I'm just going to do a really quick
thing to talk about what this is and
what the data separation path is. So, if
we're down here and we have like our UI,
which is a React component. Let's we'll
use a recipe as an example. I don't know
how to spell, but we'll assume that
spelling is not a thing that I have to
care about anymore thanks to LMS. Um, we
have a recipe example. And what does a
recipe take in? Well, this renderer
takes in a type of recipe.
This takes in a recipe data model. And a
recipe data model is just a class or I
guess interface in JavaScript TypeScript
that has a name string
uh number of servings
in
and on top of that it's going to have a
couple more things which are ingredients
which is going to be a string array
And it's going to have a instructions
finger array as well. Well, all of us
know how to render this type. I don't
have to write the react for code for
this. Any chat GBT model can do this.
So, all I need to be able to do is
provide some sort of backend service
that can somehow produce this recipe
type. And if I am able to do that, then
this UI should just work. and any
interactivity I build on this, for
example, a recipe slider that multiplies
um oops, ingredients is wrong. We'll
need something else.
Um, in order to make this interactive
based on number of servings, I actually
need to uh change my data model a little
bit
and I need to write it
>> where ingredients needs to be a list of
items.
But if I did this, it should be possible
to make for me to make an interactive
recipe view pretty straight in a
straightforward manner.
This is really clear how I would turn
this into React components and render
the different things and however I
wanted and I could have the slider logic
and stuff.
>> Exactly. The problem however that I'll
run into is
right now as as of right now if I had an
LLM generate a recipe type I won't
actually be able to send it to the model
until it's done.
So that's kind of the problem that I
want to talk about today. How do you get
around this? And how do you make it so
that this interactive component doesn't
turn into a nightmare of code?
>> Uh,
>> can I change this to interface real
quick? That's going to bother me.
>> Sorry. Yes. Uh, that's a good point.
Um, and we really, really want to go
nail this problem. The thing is, this
problem is actually really quite easy.
It's not that hard. Um, and I think
we'll be able to do this in real time
when I screen share over here. Let me
pull this up over here. Give me one
second.
Okay. And then let me screen share my
actual VS Code to show how we'll turn
this thing into code.
Share VS Code. Actually, I'll just share
my whole desktop. And again, as per
usual, if you see anything you're not
supposed to see, please let us know.
We'll clip it from the video and um
we'll keep going.
So right over here I have a very very
basic uh next.js app that I just made.
You can see if I have the commands that
I ran. I basically just ran pnvpm create
next app and added baml into it. Um and
the only thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to go ahead and just start off
first with just a example of the exact
thing that we did which is recipes.
I can't type.
My computer doesn't let me type. Okay,
that works.
I'm going to zoom in and write this over
here. We want to start off with function
generate. Oh, there you go. Okay, cool.
name string ingredients
uh servings
and then class ingredient. Okay, cool.
It kind of figured it out over here
anyway. I didn't have to write any code
which is kind of nice.
Cool. And let's just play around with
this prompt really fast and see what we
do. Uh let me know if this font size is
acceptable for everyone else.
Yeah.
>> So, right over here, we're going to make
a recipe. And this will be like, let's
say like uh I love SOG paneer. Uh that's
what I had for dinner last night. So,
let's let's use that.
>> I want a recipe for so paneer.
>> All right.
>> When I go run this, uh someone's
talking. Can you mute them, Dex? Okay.
>> Yeah, I got it.
>> Go run this. The first thing that's
going to happen is the model's going to
start generating stuff.
>> And I'm going to try and show some
subtle stuff along the way. So you can
see how it's streaming and how it's
actually rendering stuff. I don't know
if you guys caught that. I'll rerun it
really fast.
So you can see how it's streaming.
>> Okay. So on the on on the left you have
broken JSON and on the right you're kind
of just like always producing a valid
object. Right.
>> Exactly. So this is pretty much a
guarantee that BAML does for you. So now
you don't have to worry about this. But
there's something that kind of bothers
me over here, which is ingredients don't
really mean anything until the full
ingredient has come out of it. I don't
really want ingredient to be used. I
don't really care if the name is paneer,
but the quantity is uh is not yet
defined because the model's only printed
out these tokens. How could I do that?
Well, one thing you can do is we can
just tell the model that, hey, this
thing only should come out when it's
actually done. So every ingredient will
only stream as it's done. So I'll show
you what that means. Now you'll notice
the streaming mechanism only prints out
the whole object instead of partially
regardless of what the model is doing
along the way. So what this does is it
actually gives you good guarantees on
the types of the object over there. On
the other hand, instructions, I'm
actually very happy to have these stream
out along the way because they're long
forms of text. So it's not that useful
for me to have it.
That said, the serving size is almost an
essential necessary thing that I need.
So why don't we also tell the model that
hey this thing cannot be null when it's
processing it needs to be at least
somewhat present. So now when I actually
run this even if the model has dumped
out some tokens until the serving size
has appeared nothing will be rendered at
all to the model. So it allows me to go
and control this purely by giving some
minor annotations into the code. what
these small things I did make a huge
impact in exactly how
>> the stuff is actually going to be
rendered in the UX that happens.
>> So you don't push an an ingredient into
the final object until the whole
ingredient object has been streamed.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay.
>> Sick. I haven't gone super deep on this
part of BAML or doing this like
otherwise. I know like AI AI SDK has
some stuff that kind of does this. Um,
but this is really cool to see.
>> I'll show you the exact manifestation.
And this is really subtle, so see if you
can catch it. Um, of what this actually
does.
Let's see if the images load. Once I do,
give it a second. There we go. Okay.
See if you guys can see what's happening
over here.
Anyone have a guess?
I'm just streaming numbers and a plot
line. I'm plotting uh how many
tablespoons of water are there on Earth
and I'm accumulating numbers. And here I
asked it to list out a bunch of XYZ
coordinates.
>> All right. Where's our super cracked
chat? Tell us what's going on here.
>> So exactly it it defaults to zero.
That's part one. The other thing it's
doing is while the numbers are actually
generated, LLM spit out numbers from
left to right, which is reasonable.
That's how I write them as well. So, it
actually renders a five, then a 53, then
a 530, and a 53,000. It actually makes
for a very, very, very jarring
uh UX on there. But what if you said
that, hey, numbers can't actually stream
until they're fully done by default?
Well, once you do that, you now get a
view like this. It's a little bit
slower,
but every single point is rendered at
the exact same point that it needs to be
on the XYZ axis without you having to
think about it. And what this means is
there's no point at which rendering this
graph that it's invalid or incorrect.
There's no such thing as an invalid
state. It's incomplete, but there's no
invalid states like this where it's like
slowly hopping up to the right digit.
And more tangibly, what this leads to is
if I was rendering this graph, which is
just book popularity over time. You can
see how this would be much much harder
to deal with without you having to think
if you had to think about this along the
way. This axis would just not work cuz
you'd render at one. So your graph yaxis
would snap all the way to the left and
then go all the way down along the way.
>> Question in the chat. How do you
determine when a number is complete?
a lot of algorithms uh that we've built
out there. You can go read the BAML
source code. But the idea is that if we
know what fields what fields are in a
data type or something else, we can
basically run a bunch of heristics to
know if a number is complete along the
way or not. For example,
>> the simple the simple version. Yeah, go
ahead.
>> Let's take an let's take an example of
like an integer for example. If I'm I'll
draw on my screen. If an example is like
if you know that the type is an integer
and the model spit out one two three,
you don't actually know if it's complete
yet. But if the model put a comma there,
you also don't know if it's complete. If
a model put a period there, you also
don't know if it's complete because you
could be in Europe um or you could be in
Europe instead of um in America because
periods don't mean something else. But
on the other hand, if the model put a
question mark there, you know it's
complete.
So you can kind of have intuition about
how numbers are going to be dealt with
uh in different contexts based on what
you know
and we just have done a lot of this work
under the hood for you.
>> Uh kind of
>> right like I would be looking for a
comma, right? It was like if I integer
specifically integer and JSON I feel
like is an easy one. You're like okay
when is the field like JSON has a field
terminator which is a comma in most
cases or a like closed bracket for the
object.
>> Exactly. So let me let me go into
Exactly. So that's kind of how we can
build intuition hunches around this. Let
me clear my notation.
>> So we need reax or grammar for every
data type basically. I'll clear it.
>> Yeah, that's kind of what the BAML
parser does under the hood. But what
this lets you do is I want you guys to
take a look at this UI really fast and
see if you can catch the difference. and
it's named incorrectly, object and
array. But there's a very subtle
difference here.
>> I like the I like the the second one
better. I like the array one better.
>> What do you like about it better?
>> I I don't know. It just feels more pol I
mean the other one is like more
interactive. It has more like the where
the token stream one by one. It feels
more but like just feels super polished.
>> I think it's just I think what I
>> what I would describe it as is u Andre
Karpathi talks about this autonomy
slider all the time. But here we kind of
have like this UX slider of how much
streaming do you want to do? The object
one is basically full streaming. Stream
every token as soon as it comes there
like show the user everything. The array
one is somewhere down here which says,
hey, I'm only going to show you cards as
they finish and nothing else. And a
totally different approach would be,
hey, I'll show you nothing until it's
completely done and then I'll show you
the whole thing all at once. It's not to
say any one of these are better or
worse, but definitely your users will
have a preference for different ones of
them. And what you'll want to do is
you'll want the ability to control that
very trivially. So you can actually go
ahead and decide what you do.
>> I would almost want like I feel like
something in the middle would be really
good. Like not don't stream every single
token, but like show the header and then
once all the text is there, show all the
text in one go. Like the streaming every
token just feels like chat GPT and it
feels like every AI app I've ever seen.
The second one feels like it is real
time and I can tell it's AI. Maybe if
there's like a spinner here after each
one of these. But like I I yeah I think
there's like yeah having I think I think
your point about like having control and
granularity on every field is is the
right one to be focusing on.
>> Exactly. And I think the point here is
like the thing that differentiates most
AI applications today is purely the UX
and this is a big part of the UX of how
you're actually streaming stuff around.
So why don't we take this example that
we're building out here, the recipe
example to fruition and just complete it
uh in complete it.
Let's do this.
So what we have here is we have a
function called generate recipe. It's
going to take in a recipe produce a
recipe data model. We put some streaming
traits around it. So we actually get to
know that hey servings it won't pop up
until servings are complete. Um, let's
also guarantee that name will also exist
at all points. Like this data model is
kind of useless until the name and the
servings are done.
Uh, ingredients, they don't have to be
done. Uh, they don't have to like I
don't I'm okay if the ingredients aren't
yet started, but I definitely want to
make sure that ingredients only pop in
as an ingredient is fully complete. And
lastly, I want to make sure that
instructions only pop in uh can stream
as much as they want. I don't really
care. So, let's build a UI for this um
really quickly.
layout.tsx page.tsx.
Um, so I'll just do this in the main
React app because I why not? So the
first thing I'll do is import.
>> Okay. So this is and this is I guess is
using the built-in BAML generator for
creating for creating like React hooks
that you can use to stream this stuff
down.
>> Exactly. So it's just it will just do
we'll do purely purely on the react side
but we don't have to think about
anything
from
client slash react slash hooks
use generate recipe
>> nice
And what I have here is I've used
generate recipe. This thing is going to
spit out data to me. It's either going
to be a recipe type or undefined.
And I think it streams by default.
So, and the type of data is going to be
as you can see name is guaranteed. Uh
where is this? Oh, sorry.
If data
data name is guaranteed to be there as
it's filled in name dot
name
ingredients.m mapap
I
and all these are guaranteed to be
completed along the way. So I actually
don't have to worry about streaming over
here because this thing will just do the
streaming work for me and it basically
guarantees that my type system matches
the type I have over here. In theory, if
I remove this and I only use
ingredients, then unit should become oh
data is
when I'm writing ingredients unit
becomes uh where is this?
Let me just make sure the types.
>> Okay. So the the point here while you're
while while you're fixing that I guess
the point here is that you don't have to
put like question mark everywhere to do
these like optional checks on everything
because you're like okay once once an
item is in that array I can guarantee
from the parser that that field will be
non-null rather than having to be like
okay if this is true then show it
otherwise don't show it and have all
these like conditional checks down like
streaming into my render function or
leaking down into my render function
basically
>> I can put all that logic declar
comparatively in my class definitions.
>> As 408, is that right?
>> Sorry, I write a lot more Python code
than type code.
>> Scale issue.
>> Yeah, probably
uh ingredient. Yeah, when I go do this,
unit becomes like optional when I'm
actually returning this type along the
way. So, let me catch up to what we're
doing again. So what we're doing here is
we're calling the generate recipe method
we have in a streaming mechanism. For
every single instance that we get of the
stream, we loop through every ingredient
and we see unit. Unit is a string or
undefined. But if we go back here and we
actually say that ingredient can only
pop in when it's done. Then in theory,
unit should actually no longer be
undefined. It should only be defined at
compile time. And that is exactly I
think what happens.
There we go. That's exactly what
happened. So unit now becomes known at
compile time. So now I when I do
rendering, I know how to render
ingredients and I just render an
ingredient with this thing. So when I
actually render the new quantity, I can
do unit quantity times
uh dunk dot servings. And this is
guaranteed to be a number. There's no
streaming constraints. So I get a lot of
simplicity. Otherwise, what I would have
to do if I didn't have all these things
on here.
>> Okay. Okay. And the is the chunk going
to be the incrementally updated object,
right? It's not it's not just the like
diff of the tokens that were sent. It's
literally every chunk that comes off of
that iterator in in Typescript is going
to be the full object.
>> Exactly. Otherwise, now to build a
reactive component, I have to write some
code like this. And if every single time
I want to build some sort of
interactivity, I have to write code like
this, I basically won't do it because
I've made life a lot harder for myself.
So what I find is adding a few type
constraints on here can go a long way in
terms of making life easier for
developers to actually go ahead and
build the system that they want under
the hood because now this thing reflects
the type system correctly and I'm
reflecting my UX in the type system. So
now rendering a UI object off of this
ingredient type is just infinitely
easier
>> because yeah, what I can do now is I can
say Oops. Yeah, let's I would love to
see this like mixed in with a nonI
generated variable like your slider or
something.
>> Well, exactly. So now you just do like
you say something like this. So let me
show you that code. I'm going to go
write this over here.
There we go. Okay. Um so when I go write
this, I'm going to say like
state uh servings.
>> Oh, I see. Okay. So, you have a state
thing here. Cool.
>> I have a state right over here. And what
I will do here is I'll say like
now I have to actually make another
object.
And then you're going to iterate over
this.
And because I'm doing the partial
version of it, I'm going to render a
recipe from the partial versions of it.
I don't suppose this uh Okay. Well, I
will
Sorry, I uh finish the original demo and
then uh and then we can come here and
make it toggleable.
>> Well, I can I can write the UI type out
really fast. It's not good.
>> Yeah.
>> So, what I'll do over here is now I'll
do this and I'll do use effect as long
as I have stream data. What I'll do is I
will take the serving scale and I'll say
sets
set recipe.
>> Yep.
They're right over here. I'm going to go
multiply this together.
>> And as soon as I
>> Okay, so you're just basically
>> overwriting the recipe and then mapping
it in to update the quantity.
>> Uh I'm actually silly. I've I haven't
written front end code in a very long
time.
I'll do this. I have to import this.
Uh as soon as I get streamed, I do this.
And now what I will do is
I don't actually know how to build a
renderer in
>> I'm sure I'm sure uh I'm sure Claude can
help you out with this.
>> There you go. I'm just going to go fill
this in. It's going to fill it in for
me. I like if not recipe. Cool.
Uh
um and I'm going to go fill this out.
And what I'll say is ingredients will
convert over here. Um
e
add a little bit of space.
Oops.
There you go.
And now I've built myself a nice little
unified symbol right over here.
>> Oh man, we got some React experts in the
crowd telling you that.
>> Yeah. So I apologize for not being a
React expert. Um, but what you
>> we will push this code. You should put a
PR in and uh update it to be more
correct.
>> Uh what you do over here is you just do
you just take the quantity and just
multiply by the serving skill and then
you can turn this into a slider in React
along the way and go do this. So if I
actually were to show you the real code,
um I actually wrote this code with
actual react and you can go
the exactly what we do where we actually
have like we do the exact same thing
that I was showing earlier which is we
have servings that we set over here then
we have servings ratio and then we
basically use a slider to go and change
the ratio along the way and that sets
the number of servings. So the initial
state is always set by the recipe
providing me a number of servings. And
then we just use the serving state to
tell me what I'm doing.
And what this lets me do is when I go do
this, I just take
if uh where is this? Sorry, let me find
this.
Every single time I list out an
ingredient recipe, I just list it out
with the ratio of the serving ratio. And
that solves the problem for me. If I go
down to here and I show you what this
code looks like. Oops. Over here.
This thing render.
We made too many abstractions when we
did this.
>> Yeah, actually like you probably don't
even need to use effect if you're just
computing it live in the thing. But
>> yeah, probably not. Uh, well, we use a
slider to go do it. So I maybe we do. I
have no idea. I'm not a React expert. I
do mostly Rust code sadly. But we're
able to is we just take the amount and
we just like format it according to
this.
>> And
>> the reason that we do format amount is
because it turned out that when you
actually multiply numbers together, you
actually don't get nice fractions. And
what I wanted to do over here in this
UI, if you take a look at this is notice
what I actually do is I actually have
like halves with like proper UTF UTF8
half tokens and 14 tokens and etc.
So I actually wanted the fractions to
look good. So we did a little bit more
effort to take the fraction you have and
actually render in a really really nice
way.
>> But again, these sort of things aren't
possible. And there's nothing I can do
in the LM prompting to actually make it
render this out in the right way.
There's just it's just not possible.
>> Also, if you have a scale that can
measure four and 38 grams of something,
there's might be other problems going
on.
>> Oh, my skill can do that. You just need
a better You just need to cook more.
Um, but I I think a large part about
what the conversation today is about is
really around like designing these UXs
and different challenges that you can
have. So, one of the most basic things
we showed you is you can go and control
exactly how you're streaming along the
way. But I think another thing that's
worth talking about is actually like
what is the implication of this?
Assuming you can go build this, what are
interesting UI things you can do to
actually make life better for your
users? Because building is one part, but
another thing you can do in this
approach is now let's say I'm building
an invoice generator. So we've all seen
a lot of invoice generators. If I'm
actually streaming out objects and I
have certain things be like editable.
What I could actually do in this in this
UI, imagine this is an invoice thing is
or but in the same case of recipes, I
could actually put an edit icon right
next to chicken breast and say I'm going
to edit chicken breast and replace what
500g is because I know the real answer
should actually be like 750 grams for
four servings
or the unit should actually be like one
breast or two breasts instead of 500
gram of chicken breast. So, I can
actually make edit uh UI components that
are editor editor only edit the state of
this. And even though the LM is
constantly going to be spitting out
chicken breast 500 grams, I have edited
it to be one breast or um Thank you.
I've edited it to be a single amount.
So, if you're building any sort of
application, you can actually like build
a user interactivity flow much much much
sooner than you think. So, if you're
doing I know folks that are running like
that are generating like on the order of
like 8 to 5,000 5 to 8,000 tokens out of
LLMs.
If your user can only interact with your
component at the end of 5,000 or 8,000
tokens, you've basically built an async
workflow.
>> Like your user is basically tab and come
back to it later,
>> which is a totally different mindset to
go in.
>> If um let's say my code a bit a lot of
your engineers, you've probably seen
this one.
um my code is compiling
>> um my tokens are my LM is generating
like my tokens are streaming it's the
same thing like the gap is long enough
your users will leave and go do my AI is
thinking exactly your users will leave
and go do something else and it doesn't
matter if you made it a little bit
faster because fundamentally what's
going to happen is your user is
distracted. So, if you can keep your
user more engaged, you can actually lead
to a higher outcome workflow much much
much faster. And for anyone that's
building agent code, you're basically
doing structured outputs all the time.
You're basically just streaming
structured outputs. That's what tool
calls are
>> cuz yeah, you're showing the tools,
you're showing the thinking, you're
showing the like, okay, here's what's
happening. No, I love this. This is this
is sick. I've been meaning to play with
this for a while and I haven't had a
chance to. Um, are you guys still
talking about that? You showed me like a
to-do app a while ago which was like
even more interactive, right?
>> Is that still live? Is that still
kicking?
>> I think so.
>> And then we should probably we should
probably transition to uh questions and
stuff.
>> Yes. So, let's see if I can get this
to-do app kicking. Um so, like this is
one example what you can do with a to-do
app. And again, these structured
outputs, let me refresh this.
Um sadly, this is not maintained by my
team. is maintained by me and I am not a
very good reactive and probably we
should put someone on this in a better
way. Uh so I'm going to go run this
really fast. It's like I'm a um I want
steps I want by things to get better at
chess.
And so when you do some sort of
streaming here, you can see that this
thing is actually uh
create five steps. No, create five
steps.
Remove
that task.
Five steps.
No, this did not work. Did not. Let me
reset this.
>> I thought you just put in your to-do
items and then you like tell it what's
been done.
>> We swapped this to use a really dumb
model and I was curious how that would
behave. There you go.
Okay.
>> So, what did what and you guys saw
something kind of interesting here,
which is this thing actually streams
everything.
This thing only streams as it comes out.
I'm a pro chess player.
I'm a pro.
I do chess.
I think this will work. And what's
interesting here is actually adds
another tag to it dynamically along the
way. But now as a you as a as a user I
can say like I actually just did this
myself or I can uncheck this. So I've
built interactivity into an application
that is almost typically only LM
powered. If I go through and said like
I reviewed
games yesterday
and all of this is actually just
streaming streaming results. It doesn't
feel like it. It feels like it's an
agent, but I'm actually streaming
everything, the entire background. And
that's what makes it, I think, feel a
lot more natural. It is very, very
similar to the example that I was
showing over here, which is the
difference between this versus this.
I have chosen to be on the more the left
hand side of the streaming here, where I
don't want to stream everything. I only
want to stream a couple of things.
>> This is dope.
But I'll open up to questions today. Uh
Dex, firstly, what are your thoughts on
this kind of stuff? H how do you
envision people using these kinds of
tools?
>> Uh I mean, I'm obsessed with coding
agents, so I'm just kind of sitting
around thinking about like almost none
of them support streaming. Codeex kind
of does, but it's a mess. And like I
would love it. I think open code has
some good streaming stuff in it, but
it's like there's there's so much you
can do to make the UI more interesting
when you give kind of the model a
stateful object to interact with and
either like patch and send updates to or
uh it almost feels like I don't know I'm
I'm I'm getting like flashbacks to 10
years ago when I was like learning about
the React virtual DOM and you basically
just have like a system interacting with
like a set of state um and it feels much
more like if you're building browser
like the browser was designed to handle
this kind of stuff. And I feel like
we're in like the stone age in terms of
hooking LLM up to be able to interact
with visual state in that world.
>> What's really interesting actually on
that idea is I' I know a couple of
people that do this, which is
ingredients are really just an array of
items.
But there are a lot of scenarios where
you ask an LLM to talk about generate an
array of items. But if you know that the
items are only coming in as they
complete, you can actually kick off
future workflows
on top of those items. So if you're
going to run like a if if you're going
to run like a item uh what
>> oh like emit the item and then go do a
deep research to like hydrate it with
like links that I can click on to learn
more or something.
Like if you were going to go write this
kind of task, it's like uh it like use
LM for research
on I typically this thing would be a
thing that you would have like think
about your latency workflow here. You'd
have to generate every item and then go
do this. But now you can actually go
build this out really really easily
simply by running an iteration loop on
every single item that comes through.
So like the speed boost that you get is
just insanely high along the way.
Uh and I think coding agents especially
can make a lot of uh benefit from this.
Um someone asked a really interesting
question. You talk about birectional
communication managing state between the
front end and the back end.
>> Thoughts about a couple of different
things.
Um, birectional state is a thing we
talked about a lot last episode as well
and the voice agents and in the
interruptability thing. So, I'll pull
that up really fast.
Also, Dex, is your website up? We should
give you an exact one to one copy of
this stuff.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> I actually load up everything down here
and I think we have whiteboards where we
talked about how birectional agents
work. It's actually a pretty complicated
system to go build out because the
fundamental problem is biirectional
stuff especially when you're streaming
is choosing exactly when you interrupt
the thing that's streaming to inject the
new information. um if that's of
interest at this concept uh episode 19
interruptible agents probably talks
about it in a lot more detail albeit
it's a very specific use case of how you
um how you actually how you do it in
terms of interruptions but the exact
same things in terms of birectional
you're basically interrupting the stream
to go rest steer it in some other way
>> I have one question for you before we
get into the rest of the questions did
you just ask me if my website was up
>> for the code for the code thing. Uh it's
>> Oh, you mean the new the new website?
>> Yes, the new one. It's so freaking cool.
>> It's coming. It's coming. We're going to
ship it Friday. Uh keep an eye on Hacker
News on Monday. Um there will be fun
things, fun fun announcements coming.
>> Okay, you should copy and paste the
podcast page and put it on so then you
have access to it. It's all This
website's open source.
>> Amazing.
>> Yes. It was not meant to be a shots
fired at is your website. And so I'm
just excited to talk about it more. So I
was like, I'll link you to it.
>> Um, okay. Ice dev2 dev said I'm
>> sorry. I'm just making sure answer's
question as well.
>> You didn't comment on Agui, which I'm
curious your thoughts.
>> Let me go pull it up really fast. I
don't think I've seen AGUI. I'll pull it
up so everyone can see what it is.
>> This is the like co-pilot kit project,
>> which is awesome.
Okay, let's look at it. Um, it's a
standard protocol to help you go manage
information through your application.
Um, I haven't used it, so I don't have a
strong opinion right now. Um, I don't
really know how they do it. I think the
hardest parts about these systems isn't
actually like the isn't the hardest way
to sync these systems isn't actually
about sending data. Isn't actually about
like the UI and everything else.
Building UI, there's lots of frameworks
that go do that. This might be one of
them. The hardest things about it is
actually like the mechanics of how you
write it. So for example, the fact that
I could actually like not know this and
only use like the done version of the
ingredient type and I get the type
safety instead of having to write
something like
uh instead of
>> you have like six different renderers in
these all these different conditional
blocks of like okay if we have this show
this we have this show this otherwise
show nothing and all that stuff.
>> Exactly. It's all about like the
question like if I have to write like
for example if I have to write something
like
stream data ingredients on map and I if
the way I have to write this is I can't
actually write this I have to write
something like
this
then I've kind of lost the benefit of
any framework there's no framework that
I can really use where if I have to go
it's just the ergonomics of writing this
code is very challenging
>> it's declaring You're doing you're doing
declarative versus imperative and we all
we all know I don't know if there's any
list pads in here but we all love
declarative code over here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think so like I don't know
if the framework actually supports like
types and propagating types correctly
but if it does it it would be that's
really the most important part about
doing this stuff in my opinion.
>> Um I think we covered decision workflows
that can update based on inputs to
previous steps. I think the to-do app
covers that well. Um, could this be the
AI equivalent of progressive disclosure
UI pattern? Meaning, could streaming be
used to reduce cognitive lo while
showing the essentials to start and
letting the user choose what they want
to see?
>> Yeah, I don't I don't know who said
that, but that is probably that's a
great way to put it of what I think the
power of streaming is uh for AI
applications.
Um, and then there's someone talking
about letting the AI design the UI
itself instead of just managing the
data. Uh, I think my take on that is
probably like I wouldn't put that in a
production app that I wanted to sell to
people, but I bet you could do it for
certain use cases and it would look
really dope.
>> Well, actually, Dex, I have a way to do
this that I think would be really
freaking cool.
>> So,
>> okay,
>> I know that I know the shape of my data
over here, right? As long as I know the
type of my data,
>> what I could do is I could say, "Hey,
hey, model, I have a type that is
described with this interface. Can you
give me a React component that takes in
that interface and renders it?"
>> There's some people doing that.
>> Like there's some I think like the Tambo
guys are working on that.
>> Yeah. And I actually think it's a great
idea long term because what's
interesting now is I can actually have
one model generate the data and a second
model render it. And the rendering is a
one-time task. As soon as I know what
the shape of my data model is, I can
actually like pull it out and I just
render that React component dynamically
every single time.
>> This is like the um like the dynamic
extraction example almost where you're
like, okay, here's the here's the
document, generate a schema, and then do
the extraction, right?
>> Exactly. So I want I'll run this again.
So like what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to take this invoice. I'm going to
go run it out. And what I'm doing here
is I'm first having the model spit out
what it thinks of what it thinks the
schema of this data type is. And it does
that and it builds out the schema. And I
run a secondary task to actually extract
data from the schema.
>> Now,
>> and so you use the schema to render this
UI. And then you just render. Yeah.
>> And the third task I could have done is
say, hey, I have this schema I'm going
to produce. Give me a React component
that takes the schema and renders it.
And if I did that 100% I can make this a
lot prettier. In fact, I should probably
do that. I think this example would be
so much more fun if I built that in. You
could see something even
>> You should have a third button here that
is like dynamic render and it's like
different every time.
>> Exactly. Yeah. Um because like the AI is
generating the React component that
renders that type, but it's different
but stable. And that's an important
distinction to make along the way.
>> So that's cool. Yeah, whoever asked that
question like 100% you can do this and I
think you can do it in a way that's
actually good as long as this place that
you start with is actually a type system
and not really arbitrary code. Whether
the type system is described in JSON
schema, whether it's described in Zod,
whether it's described in BAML doesn't
really matter. But the premise of what
you do with it is um is that you use the
type system to power what the AI does
rather than uh rather than just do it
with vibes.
sick. Uh there's a lot of chatter, but I
don't see any more questions. Anybody
got any last minute things? Otherwise,
VIB Bob, let us know what uh the big
takeaway here is.
>> I'll wait one more second and see if
there's any more questions. But
otherwise, like really the big takeaway
is like when you're designing your AI
applications, spend a couple more
minutes thinking about what the UX is.
And then like if it's easy enough, if
it's literally as easy as writing one
line of code to make your object stream
to like and feel more ergonomic, just go
do it. It's not hard. It's really really
easy to make your applications feel
natural.
Um, could this be used to optimize token
usage? Streaming really doesn't optimize
token usage in any way. Uh, so I don't
think there's that would be orthogonal
things that you could do to make uh
better. If anything, streaming lets you
use more tokens without having the user
have to wait. Like you can like stream
out the thing and then be like, "Okay,
now we're doing the research." And
you're burning lots of tokens to improve
the quality iteratively over time while
not having the user have to wait 20
minutes for deep research.
>> Uh this Rolando said something really
interesting over here. You can guard
rail the design with a design system
instead of generating schema. And I
would generate a layout kind of like
this. So,
>> so you already have the components, but
it's taking from your design library to
to actually render the stuff. I like
that. That's sick. Awesome.
>> Exactly. So, then you could have a form
that literally matches the theme of your
website. And if you're using something
like Shad CN, that's kind of what you're
doing manually as a developer, but now
you just tell the AI to only use these
specific components and boom, it fits in
right away. So, it's even more it's even
more like tied together. And I think
like personally for me, this is what I'm
most excited about AI and I think we're
not really there yet as generally
engineering teams because the complexity
of doing this stuff is like like I said
if every single time I want to stream
something and make it slightly better I
have to do like five extra tokens or my
my app is going to re yell at me because
TypeScript says no. I'm just not going
to do this thing especially if streaming
partial JSON is hard. But if it's really
easy and I can add one line of code to
do the thing to make it do the behavior
I want, I'll do it more correctly. It's
the exact same thing of like why use
state and react makes it way easier to
build reactive apps because I don't have
to think about like I just change the
state and somehow React will rerender
the home component and do the right
thing. My brain cycles don't go on it.
And I think that's the same thing over
here as a developer. You probably don't
want to spend brain cycles thinking
about how to do partial streaming or any
of this stuff. You just kind of want it
to work.
Oh yeah, there's there's so much cool
stuff to build.
>> Yeah, I think so too. I we have a couple
more things that we've been thinking
about how streaming works for like long
agentic systems. So maybe we'll do a
future episode on that.
>> Uh but that is also a whole different
ballgame of how you go do that.
Um Tambo UI is pretty cool. If you
haven't checked it out, they do some
interesting stuff for generating UI
components on the fly.
>> Yeah.
Um,
>> sick y'all. This was dope. Thank you,
Vib. I have been looking forward to this
episode for a while.
>> Where do you actually persist results?
Um, so just for more context on how this
thing works.
Uh, this use generated recipe actually
comes from the BAML code you write. But
under the hood, what we do is we
actually codegen BML code. We actually
codegen react code and we code genen
react server action code
that actually does the uh that actually
makes the calls for you and then does
all the work behind the scenes to
propagate data straight to the front
end. So there's a server action file and
a um and a hook that gets codegen. So
then when you use this it's actually the
data is living in the hook itself. Um if
you go read this code somewhere down.
>> Okay. So if I wanted to, I mean that
server action was pretty pretty small.
Like if I wanted to, I could stream it
and like shim part of it out to a
database and stream the rest of it down
to a UI if I wanted to. Right.
>> Exactly.
>> Do like optimistic updates basically.
>> Um are there any um security
implications to be aware of with
streaming? Um no, I don't think so. I
mean, sometimes you might like, for
example, you might want to be really um
I can think of a couple actually that
will happen in like eventual apps. Like,
for example, sometimes I want to hide
some secret words and I don't want to
show them off to users. Um, and I think
the most the easiest example of this is
like when an LM is streaming markdown,
sometimes you'll see it go from like
title here and before it actually makes
the title bold, it just spits out like
asteris title and then eventually it
snaps to bold and I'm doing this and I
kind of as a user I kind of wish I never
rendered the asterisk at all. I just
waited until the title word popped in.
Um, and you could do the same thing with
like rendering some sort of sensitive
data where like for example a password
field should not render the raw password
until the password field is complete and
it should render as dots and the user
should opt into seeing it like envirs or
something else.
Um, you probably would have to do a
little bit more engineering work to go
solve that problem on your own in some
use case. Like if you have a raw text
field and you want to just hide parts of
it, that's just not a thing you can do.
But it it's not really a major security
flaw because the data is available
anyway. It's in the raw text. If you
wanted to cancel the data generation
like for example chat GBT does this
where like if you if you start talking
about things it's not supposed to talk
about and it starts answering in the
middle
>> it dies midstream right it's just like
oh nope
>> exactly so the way you solve that
problem if you go back and look at our
interruptions video episode 19 I think
is
you have to go interrupt the stream you
have to be monitoring the stream and
checking for something in an invalid way
and then go cancel it. Uh but that's the
only real way to go do this. There's no
inherent security problems in streaming
itself.
Uh does this work with Tanstack? Yeah,
it should it should work with Tanstack
as well. But you don't really need to
use Tanstack uh for at least these calls
because these calls are just calling the
LM directly in the server action itself.
So you don't have to make a use query
mechanism out of it along the way. It's
kind of a self-contained hook for every
function that you define.
Sick. Cool. I think that puts us at
time.
>> I am extremely jetlagged. So, uh, today
we're going to go and reset this and I'm
going to go get some rest. But it was
tons of fun. Thank you everyone for
joining. Dexter
>> super fun.
>> Real quick announcement. We are changing
we are changing the platform up next
week. We're going to try to move this to
Streamyard. So, they do have live
streaming. Um, there will be a better
chat experience. The recordings will be
much higher quality. Uh so thank you all
for the first I think it was episode 20
episode 21. Everyone here for supporting
and being a part of this community and
giving us the bringing us your energy
and your great questions. We're going to
double down on the show and maybe uh
give you all a little bit better
production quality going forward. So
super stoked about that.
>> Yeah, we are too. Um and also like
firstly thank you everyone. We just hit
I was going to make I totally forgot the
beginning. like we've uh we just crossed
1.5K subs and that is awesome to see
everyone supporting us and actually
watching these videos that start off
with just me and Dexter talking at each
other for an hour about weird AI topics.
Um
>> a lot of shouting. It wasn't just
talking.
>> We're both very passionate humans as you
as most people can probably tell at this
point. Um,
>> we're still learning to share the toys.
>> And please keep sending um topic ideas
if you ever want on our on the GitHub
for AI that works. If you ever have
topic ideas that you think would be
awesome to see, like post them on there.
If some code feels unflushed out,
comment. We'll do our best to make sure
that it's actually helpful and guiding
people in the way that they want. But
this was great, Dexter, as always.
>> Awesome. Thanks everybody. Catch you all
next week.